und jetzt drückt man darauf richtig
durch umschalten und den schaden hier
ist 50 sonst ist ein führerschein in der
probezeit ganz schnell wieder weg
das geht schneller hiermit als du denkst
hey leute was gedacht und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video und
zwar sind wir jetzt hier metro tu berlin
hat nämlich seinen führerschein
bestanden
herzlichen glückwunsch berlin das auch
noch 17
und er dafür das erst mal mit meinem
auto fahren also ich fand ihn jetzt hier
raus und dann fahren auf dem parkplatz
und dann fahren wir los so nervös nein
gar nicht
okay ich habe ja ich komme bei dir
hintenrum so wie mache ich nie dran das
ist hier und hier
hiermit erstmal ganz wichtig jetzt
sitzeinstellung das zu nahe tritt mit
dem fuß durch bekommt jetzt noch ganz
hinten und von der höhe geht die frau da
und jetzt musste noch spiegel gucken
weil ich wieder was
passt es nicht direkt hier drauf und
dann kannst du das verstehen
ich setze jetzt hier hinten weil merlin
ist nur noch 17 und begleitendes fahren
muss die spiegel einstellen ja genau
genau
die handbremse
gut
anschnallen
gute arbeit
was sagst du
gut
die bremse partner das kupplung leicht
in welchem modus war einmalig
normal comfort
kannst du einmal ein sport modus
wechseln
benzin naja kreisverkehr
das nicht die steckdose durchgefallen
ist durchgefallen
die stelle kommen gleich als ich das
erste mal meine praxisprüfung gemachter
film führerschein habe ich da so ein lkw
die vorfahrt genommen
aber ich habe das anders gesehen ich
frage da war genug platz und merkst du
nun anderes fahrgefühl als zieht er mehr
oder was das was ja
drückt man dabei im modus ein hoch hier
genau 12 x drücken und noch mal und
jetzt ganz war das aufdrücken unbegrenzt
ja ja das stimmt so nicht zu weit
vorsichtig fahren
geht doch erstmal vorsichtig von polen
bleibt man im gang
wenn die 70 jetzt vorbei ist kann es ja
einmal drauf drücken kannst du auch im
dritten gang gegen dann ist es noch ein
bisschen spektakulärer und jetzt drücken
wir drauf
richtig durch und schalten
weiter weiter weiter
sauna
ja was sagst du schon haben
er ist gut
mustang fahren
jetzt kommt hier eine gute stelle jetzt
kannst du doch mal hier ersten gas geben
wenn die
a
die kamera
aber solche straßen und auch immer blöd
vor allem die hier die sind die
eigentlich schwierig am schwierigsten
schwierig zu fahren
so jetzt ein ganzes gebiet jetzt hier
vorbei jawohl
[Musik]
und was sagst du als resümee ist gut
weil das war das super zusammen
versuchen sich gut
ich mach dich mal schnell auf den
rennstrecken modus und da ist die
traktionskontrolle aus rennstrecken
ja das gibt es auch
das wieder normal
erfahrene ausgucken
hier ist 50 sonst ist ein führerschein
in der probezeit ganz schnell wieder weg
das geht schneller hiermit als du denkst
nur 45 und er lächelt und auch ja gut so
jetzt machen wir noch kurz gutes
teamplay ja wohl nochmal noch mal
nein nein das war deine arme oben okay
leute also wir sind jetzt auf seinem
parkplatz
ich würde sagen hast du sehr gut gemacht
weiter so und wenn danach ziemlich da
muss man ja auch mal alleine fahren
ok wenn ihr meint er ist gut gefahren
das ist auf jeden fall noch nach oben da
wenn ihr meint nicht dann auch und haben
erst in einer woche stimmt also ich
finde jetzt wirklich sehr gut gemacht
ich bin überrascht und das wird im video
das doch nach oben da schaut gern bei
mehreren auf instagram vorbei oder wir
sehen uns morgen wieder und haut rein